[Musique]
après de nombreux efforts nous avons
conclu que l'air power n'atteindra pas
nos standards et nous avons annulé le
projet nous nous excusons auprès des
consommateurs qui attendait le lancement
le continue on pensait que le futur et
sans fil et pousseront cette expérience
vers l'avant dan riccio
[Musique]
c'est officiel apple a donné le clap de
fin à son air power alors le air power
pour vous re situer si vous savez pas si
vous êtes arrivé par hasard on connaître
leur point g vous expliquer leur power
c'est ça la c'est ce truc
alors on va pas forcément très bien
toute simple blanc sur blanc en fait
c'est une grande base de recharge sur
lequel vous pouviez vous auriez pu en
tout cas rechargez vos différents
appareils apple
votre smartphone vos airpod et votre
apple lance l'idée était de pouvoir
avoir effectivement une base de recharge
vous pose ithaque tak tak sa recharge
trois bobines trois bobines disposés à
l'intérieur qui vous permettez de
recharger facilement pour apple
l'idée c'est qu'effectivement il ya le
futur va vers la recharge sans fil
en gros vous avez votre base vous posez
vos affaires vous pouvez vous prenez pas
trop la tête vous poser sa charge
vous repartez avec moi c'est vraiment
transparent c'est facile c'est pratique
sauf que ça n'arrivera pas ce et repower
en tout cas qu elle qui a été présentée
en 2017
il ne sortira jamais alors je vous
refais un petit historique pour sembler
un peu dans le bain on est en 2017 on
attend avec impatience l'annoncé
officielle de l'iphone 10
on savait pas que tarifs eu de discours
l'attendait l'iphone 8 on s'est dit
qu'est ce qui varie d'aix iphone hui des
nouveautés et paf
apple nous sort un iphone 10 flambant
neuve sympa qui a un connu le succès
qu'on connaît enfin bref smartphone
plutôt cool
pendant cette présentation apple nous
présente ce qu'ils appellent le air
power cette grande base de recharge
multi accessoires qui est donc une
annonce officielle faite par la marque
c'est pas juste dire tiens on pourrait
un jour faire s'annonce une annonce
officielle voilà le et repower vol à
skis à pouvoir faire et justement comme
on lance la recharge sans fil avec
l'iphone 10 et bien air power sera là
pour recharger votre iphone très
facilement cool super promesses
on attend un petit peu les mois passent
il était annoncé par apple comme sortant
en 2018 2018 passe pas de nouvelles on a
effectivement le d'allemagne où
d'habitude ici pas de news nahla qui
note en septembre pas news le temps
passe et on dit rappelons aussi et même
fin d'année on a eu l'info que selon des
ingénieurs ça serait pas possible
techniquement comme les bobines sont
mises en place
il risque d'y avoir un gros problème de
surchauffe et du coup ça ne
fonctionnerait pas juste d'un point de
vue conception mais aucune y croire un
peu
nous annonce il ya quelques jours des
airs potes de airpod de où vous avez
deux possibilités la première ou seven
boîte vouloir changer classiquement
comme vous l'avez avec les apôtres 1 et
la deuxième version une recharge sans
fil de rosia ça y est ça avance on va y
arriver enfin ce air power puisque
l'airpod se recharge son film pour
chercher donc votre iphone votre apple
watch evo et repose plutôt cool et
quelques jours après apple nous
annoncent officiellement abandonné le
projet de r power c'est un gros revers
pour apple alors il ya plusieurs choses
à dire là dessus comme il ya plein de
choses à dire et comme vous le savez
monsieur re a fait son travail
ce qui me dérange en fait si vous le
derrière tout ça c'est pas que apple ce
plan sur sur une annonce ça peut arriver
ça peut arriver à n'importe quelle boîte
bien qu'apple nous et pas du tout
habitués chanteuse au contraire apple
c'est plutôt une boîte qui a tendance à
sécuriser avant de sortir des techno
détendre vraiment que la techno soit
prête que le marché soit mûr et qui
puisse vraiment eu la proposer dans les
bonnes conditions j'ai l'impression que
ça pulse of marketing en 2010 est de
dire eh bien voilà on sort un iphone
avec de la recharge sans fil on est
obligé d'avoir une base de recharge sans
fil qui nous appartient alors bien
évidemment si vous allez sur le site
d'apple vous allez pouvoir acheter
d'autres recharge sans fil on sait très
bien qu apple privilégie toujours de
vendre ses propres produits ce qu'on
peut complètement comprendre donc du
coup il ya eu un vrai coup de com
un coup marketing le air power il est là
il est beau il va sortir sauf qu'en fait
qu'il n'était pas du tout fonctionnel le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
concurrence est de plus en plus
pressante avec beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'acteurs sur le marché du
smartphone et des accessoires apple du
coup a voulu montrer qu'ils avaient une
vraie force de frappe aller vite avec ce
grand air power qui au final n'arrivera
jamais
sauf que le problème c'est qu'ils ont
pris problème à l'envers ils ont d'abord
fait l'annoncé sur un projet qui veulent
mettre en place les ans ça va arriver on
va le sortir que derrière ce n'est pas
du tout prêt on aurait attendu d'apple
plus de prudence en disant on va d'abord
être sûr que le produit soit fini prêt
et ensuite on verra les fabrications
apprennent on est sûr en tout cas que de
produits finis fonctionne là ce n'est
pas le cas c'est l inverse
voilà ce qu'on veut faire voilà a priori
ce qui devrait se faire et ce qui
devrait se passer
et au final le produit n'est jamais
arrivé et comme il n'est jamais arrivé
comme apple a pas réussi à le développer
comme il voulait faire c'est un sacré
revers et un sacré problème d'image pour
la marque alors au delà de ça est ce
qu'on peut toujours faire confiance à
apple
bien évidemment
là dessus j'ai absolument aucun souci ça
peut arriver de se planter sa théorie là
toutes les bref c'est dommage de voir
géants comme apple se planter sur un peu
comme ça dès lors vous n'avez pas un
produit qui fonctionne elle voulu
l'annoncer pas vous n'annoncez pas qui
va arriver l'année prochaine puisque le
produit ne marche pas puisque vous
n'êtes pas sûrs du rendu final sa vraie
vrai vrai vrai gros problème mais
l'autre problème que cela pose
d'ailleurs tout ça c'est comme je le
disais galères potts deux sont sortis le
jour ici ça c'est la boîte vers poste de
pesée pas encore ouvert je vais pas
tarder à le faire quand la question
s'est posée à moi d'aller acheter ses
airs police de données personnelles
j'avais le choix entre les acheter avec
le câble lightning pour les recharger ou
alors la version plus cher directement
en adduction je n'étais pas du tout
convaincu qui est un vrai bénéfice de
les acheter en adduction parce que je ne
suis pas énormément clients de
l'induction il ya une différence de prix
entre 179 euros et 220 de centres auto
je me souviens plus exactement le le
prix moi je me suis dit pour le prix je
vais acheter tee airpod je vais pas vous
remettez à prendre en recharge sans fil
et c'est aussi un problème aujourd'hui
pour rappel parce que si vous regardez
sur la mode des airs pote 2 pour garder
au dos vous voyez le air power qui
apparaît on voit vraiment qu'apple était
dans une phase de commercialisation
vraiment débuter à la fin on sent qu'on
n'y arrive pas ça marche pas allez stop
on coupe on arrête l'histoire ça ça va
être compliqué pour tous les vendeurs de
l'apple store
mais c'est quoi accessoires derrière
c'est un produit qu'on devait sortir
puis qu'on annule et puis qui marchent
pas compliquée a justifié
alors je sais il existe différents
accessoires sur lequel vous pouvez
l'utiliser en base de recharge en groupe
un équivalent des repreneurs qui n'est
pas air power parce que on n'est pas
dans les niveaux d'exigence calais apple
et au delà de ça ce qu'on voit c'est que
c'est un vrai revers technologique pour
apple apple innove depuis des années
apple maîtrise énormément de domaines
entre mon sujet on a du mal à comprendre
qu'il soit planté juste sur un
accessoire pour la recharge sans fil ça
paraissait pas être le défi le plus
dingue
est ce que eux mêmes ils ont sous-estimé
cette problématique en dix ans c'est
rien c'est jamais de la recharge sans
fil
on va le solutionner on le sortira en
2018 tout ira bien
comme quoi ils n'ont pas réussi ils sont
plantés et ça c'est un déficit d'image
ça veut dire quelque part que apple n'a
pas vraiment anticiper la problématique
que la copie n'a pas été vraiment prise
au sérieux ou alors il ya un chef de
projet qui s'est planté un moment en
interne comment est-ce qu'ils ont géré
ce truc comme ans a pu être gérée pour
qu'on puisse se dire ouais ok c'est bon
on est prêt ça va marcher au final un
produit qui ne marche pas du tout cool
dit une fois de plus je suis convaincu
qu apple est une excellente marque qui
innove qui propose de très bons
continuer à leur faire confiance je sais
pas vous ce que vous en pensez à ce que
vous attendiez air power est ce que vous
avez été surpris par effectivement
l'annoncé de l'annulation pure et simple
de ce produit mark et moi tout ça en bas
et au final est ce que vous avez acheté
l'airpod ce2 et est ce que vous êtes
déçu de ne pas pouvoir les utiliser avec
un power mark et moi tout ça on reste
d'elle évidemment connectés je vous
invite à aller visionner aussi d'un
playlist qui parle de pleins d'objets
connectés dans lequel on va parler dans
quelques jours de cet accessoire
donc restez connectés je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous à bientôt
[Musique]